I want to look at these meteors. I just
did a video on this like 2 days ago and
I forgot to talk about this very vital
point of this. There's been so many
sightings of these meteors this month. I
think this is highly unusual. You know,
I looked into this.
Do we have more meteor sightings now
than ever? And they said, "Oh, no. You
know, Google's saying, 'Oh, it's just
because we got more cameras and ring
cams and dash cams and all that.'" But
when I asked AI, "How many meteor
sightings have they been has there been
just this month?" month in March, and it
says March 8th, Western Europe. March
9th, Eastern USA and Canada. March 11th,
Eastern USA. March 17th, Ohio.
Caused a sonic boom visible across 12
states. It says, "So far in 2026,
10 fireballs have been significant
enough to draw more than 100 eyewitness
reports each averaging nearly one major
event per week."
One major event per week. A fireballs.
Can you think back in your whole life
and remember the last time you saw one
fireball let alone 10, okay? So
something is happening. I don't believe
that this is just natural phenomenon. If
you go back and watch the other video, I
talk about how Satan is the god of this
world. He is setting up the stage for a
grand illusion. And ultimately, he's
going to come on the scenes as a cosmic
savior that's doing lying signs and
wonders, miraculous healing. The Bible
says miracle working demons are going to
deceive the entire world to unite them
together in a battle against the coming
of Jesus Christ. Go read Revelation.
Check out the video I just did. This is
the thumbnail for that. It's called
meteor deception. Watch it because
there's a lot more information that I'm
going to be showing you right here. I
just wanted to discuss these strange
movements that people are seeing. Now,
think about a fireball coming from outer
space into our atmosphere. It's burning
up and sometimes it explodes and causes
a shock wave. And so think about a
fireball streaking across the sky. For
one, think about how fast it would be
moving. For another, would it be making
strange maneuvers? This is interesting.
Daily Mail shows some videos from Texas.
And you can see that this is a a
slow-moving fireball. And look how it's
moving down. It's like down and hooking
around. People in Texas are seeing Look
at this. It's doing a U-turn. The
fireball is making a U-turn.
Maybe I'm just crazy. Maybe I think that
fireballs go in a straight line and I
don't understand why it would be
steering around. Let me know in the
comments how a ball from outer space
comes into our atmosphere and is on fire
and making zigzag turns. Because it says
right here, "A mysterious fireball
making turns that seem to defy the laws
of physics was spotted by multiple
witnesses in Texas Tuesday night."
Videos captured the object over Red Oak.
Flooded social media revealing an orange
fireball that did not move in a straight
line like a shooting star crossing the
horizon. Instead, the object was seen
zigzagging through the sky appearing to
move closer to the ground before turning
upwards and changing direction. I hope
you guys are seeing like this is not
adding up for a fireball, a meteor
coming from outer space. While officials
have not yet identified the object
described by some as UFO or meteor,
witnesses report it emitted a bright
orange trail resembling a rocket engine.
That's very curious. A rocket engine or
a fiery trail of space rock entering the
atmosphere. The bizarre fireball was
seen just hours after a series of rare
meteor sightings across the world. This
is crazy. Like this is happening
back-to-back, okay? Just 2 days before
witnesses capture a large fireball
streaking over buildings in a populated
city of Turkey. This is worldwide, a
worldwide phenomenon
of fireballs entering into our
atmosphere that are
not going in a straight line. You know,
people are saying, "Is it advanced
secret human tech being tested in plain
sight or something far more otherworldly
like an extraterrestrial probe scouting
our planet?" Somebody says, "Meteors
burn straight paths while fragmenting
from atmospheric friction, yet this one
moves with eerie precision almost like
it's piloted." One skeptic posted on X.
That's what I'm thinking. This is not
normal. And I I looked up some more
videos because the one on Daily Mail was
kind of chopping the video off before
you saw the full maneuver. But on X,
there's something called trending 911.
And this is the video they show in full.
Now, look. It's going upwards. Fireballs
don't enter the atmosphere and go up.
They should be going down
at a 45° angle down towards the Earth.
And right here you're going to see a a
close-up of what she's seeing on her
phone. Look at the direction. Look at
the tail.
That fireball is going up. It's making a
U-turn upwards into the sky. This
I got questions, guys. Another one that
says, "Secondary video emerges." And
check this out. I see some people in the
chat saying falling angels, blue beam
showing the beginnings.
These are
government operations, I believe. That's
what I'm thinking. You know,
one of these options.
I believe these could very well be
fallen angels. You know, if we saw a
sighting like this
2,000 years ago, I think people would
not be thinking, "Oh, wow. A ball from
outer space is coming into our
atmosphere and catching on fire and
making strange maneuvers." No, we'd
probably be looking at it like this is
some god or angelic being from the
heavens.
So we have been conditioned to believe a
different way, especially about our
cosmology,
what this world is, that we're in a
ever-expanding vacuum, and there's all
sorts of shrapnel flying around and
entering into our atmosphere. Go watch
that other video I made because I go way
deeper into that topic. But this is not
what we're being told. We're being told
that these are meteors the same way
like, you know, a year ago we were being
told that there's drones in New Jersey,
but it's okay. They just keep shopping.
They They seem harmless, you know.
They're getting us used to seeing things
flying around in our skies and being
okay with it because Satan has to play
by the rules. And the thing about Satan
is he cannot have access into your life
unless you open the door in some kind of
way, whether that's the occult, Ouija
boards,
dream catchers, watching things you
shouldn't be watching, listening to
things you shouldn't be listening to,
playing violent video games. All these
things we're entertaining our minds with
evil. And when you do that, you're
giving Satan an access into your life.
And we do it in all kinds of ways that
we're not aware of. And look where we're
at today. The United States is
experiencing vastly different things
than we did 100 years ago. Why? Because
there's more evil that's being accepted
as normal and cultural and fun and
entertainment. And all of this is our
consent to allow Satan into our world
that now he is manifesting in the United
States the same way he's been
manifesting in third world countries and
places in voodoo tribes and all that
because we are not under the hand of God
anymore. We have pushed God away. We are
entertaining our minds with the most
vile, wicked things. And this is what's
happening. And it's a great deception.
Satan doesn't come out with a pitchfork
and goat hooves and horns. He comes as
an angel of light. He comes as an alien
with all the answers to our questions.
And so what is happening right now is
between government
and spiritual warfare. We are seeing
things that are flying around to put
fear in you because it's a lot easier to
control people through fear. And this is
why we have Space Force. And the
government is siding with Satan right
now and preparing to fight against
Christ. So they have to legitimize
reasons to have a Space Force, to have
weapons pointed towards the heavens.
When you start looking up verses about
the end times, you see things like there
will be nation shall rise against
nation. What is happening right now?
Literally right this moment. And the
government's saying, "Oh, it's a holy
war. This is Armageddon. Jesus about to
come soon." Our government is saying
these things. And look in Luke 21:11, it
says, "And great earthquakes shall be in
diverse places and famines and
pestilences and fearful sights and great
signs there shall be from heaven." We're
seeing fearful sights in the heavens.
People are like, "What is this? I don't
I've never seen anything like this
before." They're recording it. They're
uploading it. Everybody's watching it
and consuming it and saying, "Oh, no.
I'm scared. What is this? What's going
on in our world?" And this is feeding
the beast. This is feeding Satan
and allowing him to continue to deceive
the entire world. It's the grand
illusion that's coming. Please go back
and watch meteor deception. I just did
it like 2 days ago. I go into a lot more
evidence that these things are not what
we are being told they are. I hope this
video is eye-opening to you. I hope you
saw that meteors do not make U-turns and
fly all around like they're being
piloted. If you like this video, please
give a thumbs up. Really helps this
video get out into the algorithm. Please
click subscribe if you're new to this
channel and share this video with a
friend. It's short. It's shareable. And
I hope that it's making people think
that we can't just believe everything we